[Music]
thank you
hello and it's a seven o'clock I'm
Kamali Melbourne this is a special
program we'll be answering your
questions after four objects a shot down
over the Skies of North America in the
past two weeks
with many of the details still shrouded
in mystery the White House says China
has a high altitude balloon program
while the Prime Minister says the UK is
protected
in light of the Chinese balloon program
and this recent incursion into our
airspace
the United States and Canada through
NORAD have been more closely
scrutinizing that airspeed
we have something called the quick
reaction alert Force which involves
typhoon planes which are kept on 24 7
Readiness to police our airspace
but China has responded accusing the
United States of playing its own
balloons over China 10 times in the past
year
the U.S should first reflect on itself
and change course rather than smear
others and instigate a confrontation
hello and good evening unidentified
flying objects may usually be the stuff
of Science Fiction and conspiracy theory
but in the past two weeks they've become
the spark for a major diplomatic route
between the United States and China
after a series of suspected spy balloons
were shot down over North America now
the White House has blamed Beijing for
illegally infiltrating their airspace
for the purpose of surveillance but many
of these specific details still lie
shrouded in mystery now throughout the
day we have been asking you to send in
your questions about this and we'll try
to answer as many of them as possible in
a moment but first let's remind you of
what has happened so far
now four objects have been downed over
North America this month on Saturday the
4th of February USF 22 shot down a
Chinese spy balloon off South Carolina
on Friday another unidentified high
altitude object which was the size of a
small car was brought down well on
Saturday Canada's prime minister
confirmed another unidentified object
over the sparsely populated territory of
the Yukon in the Canadian North West was
brought down and last Snyder F-16 fired
a missile and downed another
unidentified object over at Lake Huron
on the U.S Canada border now authorities
say that the object fluent sensitive
military sites and could have been used
for spying
well in the last hour we've had the
latest from the White House let's take a
listen
in light of the Chinese balloon program
and this recent incursion into our
airspace
the United States and Canada through
NORAD have been more closely
scrutinizing that airspace including
enhancing our radar capabilities which
as the commander of North com and NORAD
General van hurk said just last night
May at least partially explain the
increase in the objects that have been
detected
slow moving objects at high altitude
with a small radar cross section are
difficult to detect on radar even
objects the size of a the Chinese Bible
which had a payload the size of roughly
three school buses were not picked up by
previous administrations or other
countries
well here in the UK the defense
secretary Ben Wallace has announced a
Security review following the incident
in North America and the pm has tried to
reassure that the UK is prepared
well I want people to know that we'll do
whatever it takes to keep the country
safe we have something called the quick
reaction alert Force which involves
typhoon planes which are kept on 24 7
Readiness to police our airspace which
is incredibly important I can't
obviously comment in detail on National
Security matters but we're in constant
touch with our allies and as I said
we'll do whatever it takes to keep the
country safe
now China has retaliated saying that the
U.S had flown balloons over its airspace
on several occasions since the beginning
of last year and a foreign Ministry
spokesperson says the US is trying to
provoke a confrontation
it is also common for U.S balloons to
enter the airspace of other countries
illegally since last year U.S high
altitude Bloons have illegally flown
over China's airspace more than 10 times
without the approval of Chinese
authorities
the U.S should first reflect on itself
and change course rather than smear
others and instigate a confrontation
I'll bring in our expert guests in a
moment to answer your questions but
first let's get the latest from our us
correspondent Mark Stone Mark good to
have you with us so we heard from John
Kirby at just about 10 or so minutes ago
what more did he tell us do we learn
anything all about exactly what these
objects are
what we saw was an attempt by the White
House to get ahead of this extraordinary
story and to try and put as much detail
out there in the open to fill the space
which is naturally at the moment given
the nature of the story being filled by
by speculation and conspiracies and even
before John Kirby an admiral who's in
charge of of communications for the
White House National Security Council
before he took to the podium President
Biden's spokesperson Karine Jean-Pierre
was at the podium and up front said with
a smile on her face there is no
indication of alien or extraterrestrial
involvement in the recent Spate of UFOs
over America she said that she loves the
film E.T but there is nothing to suggest
that this is extraterrestrial that I
have to say follows a comment by U.S Air
Force General speaking on the record but
off camera last night where he said um I
guess it was kind of a headline writer's
dream he said that he nothing's ruled
out well that was his view it's the view
of the White House that that E.T has not
landed
um but um that's the sort of bemusing um
amusing side of it much more seriously
what John Kirby did say was that they
are fully aware of a very very
comprehensive Chinese surveillance
balloon program they are absolutely
convinced that the first balloon that
was brought down last Saturday over off
South Carolina was one of those balloons
part of a surveillance program the
Chinese say it was a a weather balloon
the other three they just don't know
what they know is that they were much
smaller than the first they were lower
one of them was as low as 20 000 feet
which is well within uh the um uh the
orbit that uh that commercial airliners
fly and the reason they took them down
simply says John Kirby is because they
were posing a Potential Threat to
commercial air traffic and they
potentially had the ability to be able
to to gather data because they don't
know what they were there's a political
Dynamic to this as well the
administration of Joe Biden is aware
that on the right of politics here
they're being accused of not taking down
the Chinese balloon quickly enough they
want to get ahead of that they want to
show that they are in control of their
borders however high up those those
borders May well be and the last Point
Kamali that I think is really
interesting is the Chinese reaction
China will want an excuse for the shoot
down of that first balloon the images
that you're looking at here they will
want to be able to to retaliate and
they'll need to find an excuse now John
Kirby was asked repeatedly are there any
American
surveillance craft over Chinese airspace
no he said he was then asked are there
any American surveillance craft around
Chinese airspace and he repeated the
answer to his first question there are
none over Chinese airspace the question
of course is if there are Chinese
surveillance aircraft in the Pacific in
areas claimed by China then potentially
we we have a problem because if the
Chinese see that it is it within their
rights to shoot down one of those planes
then you can see how all this escalates
from being a joke over E.T to something
much more serious it certainly could and
mark thank you very much for that and
stay with us because we're going to
bring in our experts now for uh
continued discussion all about this um
please say we're joined Now by Thomas
Lawson former Chief of the defense staff
at the canadanian Armed Forces who's
also Deputy commander of the North
American Aerospace Defense command
better known as NORAD thank you for
being with us Thomas and Nick Pope who
was a UFO investigator for the ministry
of Defense here in the UK Thomas Nick
appreciate appreciate you both being
with us this evening and let's just
start off with the the question that uh
Marcus dismissed there and cream Pierre
dismissed as well
um How likely is this that this is
aliens who've come here
yeah I don't think it's likely at all in
this instance I'm not ruling it out of
course more generally and NASA have
their own study into that going on as I
speak but I think it's very clear that
this is espionage that we're dealing
with here of a decidedly terrestrial uh
nature so don't let's throw the baby out
with the bath water but uh I I think all
eyes should be on China and seeking a
diplomatic uh settlement to this this
situation and Thomas I guess you would
agree with that
agree uh totally
um you know it is of some concern though
how the first balloon which was up at
you know at some point in the
stratosphere
um why these other three balloons would
have been down so low you know the first
one almost seems like an elegant
Espionage uh plot the other three are
very very clumsy yeah okay well let's
let's go to some of our questions from
our viewers and we'll start with a
question from uh Connor Delaney uh
installments I'll stay with you if we
can so let's see if we can try and work
out what these objects are you've
mentioned that we think they're all
balloons that certainly that larger one
that came out of South Carolina was a
balloon what are these objects and where
do we think that they're from
foreign well the most likely thing is
that it has come from a country to the
west of North America that's the way the
winds flow in uh in this side of the
world uh therefore uh you know you look
to China which is known to have this
balloon program uh they've admitted to
the first one having gotten away from
them and called it a weather balloon
it's possible that Russia may have a
program as well it's even possible it
would be embarrassing it's even possible
that uh these craft may have been
launched out of another Asian nation
that has yet to own up but I think
that's why politicians here in Canada in
the United States are are being a little
hesitant uh to determine or at least
announce the provenance of the the other
three the last three objects yeah and
talk to us a bit about the uh that fact
and we're not quite sure about these
other three objects he said that this is
all about Espionage and your sort of
experience in this area have you come
across descriptions of objects like this
yes I have and uh I mean when I was
doing this for the UK Ministry of
Defense we got several hundred reports
each year Unfortunately they closed
their program I think because of the
stigma around the term UFO I I think
notwithstanding the prime minister's
assurances about the UK's air defense
network and what's happened in the last
few days is a very good indication that
we need to reopen a UFO program in the
UK because there's a lot of things out
there and anything in our aspects uh is
is automatically a defense National
Security and air safety issue and if
there have been gaps in our coverage
because of mindset or because The Radars
have been calibrated the wrong way then
that needs to be addressed okay let's
move on to the next question then thank
you for that this is from uh Bloodhound
who's uh put this question to us how do
we think they're being deployed Nick
first to you
I I well I think I think there's a lot
of options here
um some some of these May well have been
launched from mainland China but uh you
know I think there's been a lot of
speculation recently about drones uh
launched perhaps from from ships whether
they're Navy ships or whether they're
fishing vessels but uh you know
controlled by by the PRC so uh there's a
lot to get into and of course
intelligence agencies will be looking at
this right now they may have some of the
answers not probably all quite yet and
obviously because of the security
concerns not everything is going to be
made public over the next few days
though I'm sure more will emerge and
Thomas are you expecting as Nick said
for more to emerge especially about
perhaps how these things are being
deployed and what will it tell us about
uh these things and their in their use
how they are actually being sent across
North America do you think
well I I think that the efforts going on
right now to uh gather up the the
remains of these objects now that
they've been shot down uh are uh all
pointing to uh Gathering intelligence to
answer that very question and uh you
know I think as soon as the
technological fingerprint comes back uh
then uh Canada the United States uh
assuming it is China perhaps Russia will
then have some very good uh leg to stand
on when it comes to diplomatic
discussions uh but I I do as well agree
with Mr Pope that you know as these
apertures are opened by NORAD
um there is a greater likelihood that
more of these things uh will be found uh
so it's hard to tell how many are
airborne now and how many it may well be
that the Chinese would love to call back
20 more balloons that now uh are up in
the stratosphere now that they've been
caught what if they can call them back
all right let's move on to the to the
next question we've got the this is from
Dave and I'll start with you Thomas on
this one using your former fighter pilot
hat if you could or helmet why would the
US use
um such expensive missiles to bring down
these craft
yeah I you know to the average uh uh
viewer uh it would seem like a very
simple thing to bring one of these
things down it's not
um you know I was dating back a couple
of decades uh I don't think I had a
weapon I was carrying back then that
would bring one of these uh balloons
down if it was up above 40 000 feet just
too high to get up there to use guns uh
heat-seeking missiles had nothing to
lock onto and there was probably not
enough radar or cross-section from
anything that was hanging from the
balloon to allow me to shoot a sparrow
so I was one of the few people in the
Canada and the United States who was
quite impressed with the fact that uh
the f-22s last week had a missile that
could do that and it really speaks to
the technological advances that they've
made with this aim9 Sidewinder the X
model which uses infrared but not in a
way that I used to use it it actually
uses infrared to develop uh an image and
once it can see the image it can track
in uh and uh come very close to the
balloon and when it explodes rip all
kinds of holes through so I I was very
impressed with it uh and and quite
clearly uh this Weaponry has advanced uh
very well in recent years uh Mark Stone
I want to bring you in on this if I can
on that because John Kirby was asked a
question about the missiles that were
used during that press conference how
did he respond and how is that going
down because these missiles they're 400
000 each
yeah well politically as I said they
they are Keen to show that the Biden
Administration is
um doing what it should be doing
protecting National Security uh even if
there is only a potential threat against
National Security uh they were very he
was very pointed about the fact that the
previous administration of Donald Trump
had not even spotted similar balloons
that were were going over China over
American airspace
um but so they're very keen to to show
that they are doing something but in
terms of why they're using such
sophisticated equipment to take them
down well it kind of to repeat what what
um what was just said this is all that
is that they can use to take them down
and why they can't be more detailed
about what what it is they're seeing
well the excuse for that is that the
pilots of these jets are flying at
supersonic speed past an object that is
effectively stationary
um floating in the air and so they are
getting just a glimpse of of what it is
that they are shooting at which which is
why even they the eyes that are closest
to the objects are not able able to give
a detailed assessment of what it is that
they're looking at that that on the face
of it um it seems to be the explanation
of why we the public don't have a
greater understanding of what these
these objects are and and he was asked
at one point by one of the reporters in
the room that are we calling them
balloons or are they still just objects
and he said they're still just objects
so it raises the question if they're not
balloons um how are they Airborne I mean
I I don't know the answer to that one
well that's not one of the questions
from our viewers but we'll we'll try and
get it answered anyway Marcus it's a
good question as well I've been thinking
of because John Kirby and his press
conference said that they didn't seem to
have propulsion systems I mean uh Nick
what do you what did you make of that
you know these these things are up there
without propulsion How is how's that
operating
well I think that's one of the questions
we've got to answer fairly urgently and
that's why recovering as much debris as
possible is is uh one of the urgent
things to to do now I mean I think I
don't think he was definitive on that I
think uh the the answer as I understand
it was um you know they weren't yet sure
what if any so I think like like a lot
of the statements uh he was hedging his
bets on this I mean obviously with
balloons whatever propulsion system
there is wind is going to play a key
part but if China has a sophisticated
program with a number of different
surveillance platforms which is highly
likely then we may be looking at a mix
of of balloons airships drones and and
such like and and so have any of those
got exotic novel propulsion systems uh
we need to find out and it does make you
wonder as well uh Thomas that if we when
they do eventually recover the debris
for this and if they do discover a
propulsion system that perhaps uh the
technology they're not aware of or not
sure about whether we'd ever find out
what kind of system was being used
it will become very evident uh if indeed
there was some sort of propulsion system
attached to the payload underneath uh it
will become very clear I don't think it
we're going to find any uh new type of
propulsion system I think what we'll
find out is I mean when these balloons
are being pushed along at uh you know
150 kilometers up in the stratosphere
all you can really do is slow the Flight
of the balloon down uh it's not a
dirigible or a zeppelin like we know
from the old days so I think if indeed
there was any propulsion system at all
it just would have been able to slow the
uh the balloons the objects uh travel
across continental US and Canada
okay let's move on to a question uh then
from Asha out of the four objects shown
what does the debris Show and Mark uh
what have we seen so far because
obviously we've recovered some of the
debris from the one that came down of
South Carolina
yeah the debris uh from all four of them
uh in terms of where the debris landed
is is in very very different
um terrain which is which is causing
different problems the first one the
balloon that came down over off the
coast of South Carolina they have
managed to uh to recover some of the
debris they they think that the main
payload which itself they say was the
size of a small plane
um extraordinary size they think that's
intact mostly intact it's in about 50
feet of water at six or seven miles off
the coast of South Carolina and the
process to recover that is now well
underway and they they'll be taking that
to the FBI labs in Quantico in Virginia
we think where that will be analyzed
that's that um the the Downing yesterday
uh in a lake off the coast of Michigan
that is in very very deep water we
understand so the recovery of that will
be will be much harder and of course
it's smaller so that will be harder make
it hard again the recovery of the of the
debris and Yukon that is in the far
Northwest of Canada that's in what's
being described as Wilderness very
sparsely populated even getting to it
will take significant time and then and
then the one off the coast the northern
coast of Alaska or off the town of dead
horse that is on on or under Frozen ice
um depending on how thick the ice was
how big the debris was that was the one
that was the size of a small car
um it's either resting on Frozen iced or
it's cracked through it so so a very
complex challenging operation to recover
that but what we do know is that they
are sharing all that they discover with
allies Tom toogen tougain hat is the the
British Minister for security who
happened to be in Washington last week
I'm pretty sure he was given a detailed
secure briefing about what they
discovered so far about the Chinese
balloon and all that sort of information
will be being shared with with other
other allies as and when they discover
it indeed all right let's move on to a
question if we can a gentleman from
Wayne cutter and this is about out
Russia and China are saying that they've
recently shut down similar objects in
their airspace I mean we've seen the
Chinese response earlier from the
foreign Ministry saying that some 10
balloons from the US have passed over
their airspace and they hadn't uh taken
them down I mean what credibility do we
give Nick to sort of these accusations
that this is happening
um in our airspace so we're perhaps we
should let it happen in yours
I think anyone denies that pretty much
everyone is engaged on an Espionage on
everyone else but I'm not privy to the
specifics so I I can't really speak to
that what I can say is that of course
sometimes these sorts of counter
accusations are just meant to to muddy
the waters and to deflect people from
from the real issue uh you know one is
tempted to say well if if this is true
and and if any have been shot down for
example uh show us the debris as we've
shown some of the the debris but uh
again all this is happening in the
shadowy world of intelligence and and
people just obviously don't like to to
show other people what uh hand of cards
they're holding yeah absolutely and
distraction tactic would you say uh
Thomas and of course we're talking about
it being a Chinese spy balloon and the
suggestion being that these balloons are
a Chinese origin but you mentioned your
first answer that we're not certain
where they come from and it could well
be Russia I mean your experience with be
one system do you think that these four
devices are a part of or could they be
separate
okay they could well be separate they
they could be collecting different types
of intelligence some of them could be
Electro Optical some that could be
infrared some of them could be for elite
electronic uh intelligence but uh but I
I do think uh to what Mr Pope just said
I agree completely um you know that this
is a typical of an authoritarian a
nation uh to throw a smoke screen up uh
you know in elected democracies
typically what we do uh is take
responsibility and then try and make it
right I mean when I was the chief of
Canadian defense if one of my vehicles a
ship uh an aircraft or anything else
went into someone else's Sovereign
territory I would have been called on
the carpet would have answered to it and
we would have gone into a diplomatic
mode to try and help those who had been
harmed or either offended or harmed as
quickly as possible
um you know here uh China while they
took responsibility for sending this
thing over they called it a weather
balloon what's a big deal about that and
now have brought up these 10 balloons
that they talk about well why wasn't
that on the table before why weren't we
dealing with this diplomatically before
so I really do agree that that's a smoke
screen and that uh the Chinese are are
using that now to dispel attention uh
from what what their program really does
yeah and let me just stick with you if I
can and Thompson and they drill down
into that a little bit more because
obviously the concern here is that with
the Downing of these devices if they are
Chinese devices that then um suggests as
Mark was saying earlier that there could
be some kind of retaliation perhaps in
the future How concerned are people
within the security infrastructure that
this could be the beginning of something
that becomes like a Tit for Tat in some
regards
yeah well that is the greatest worry uh
when you're not speaking and by the way
uh your viewers may be aware that uh
upon uh the arrival of um uh the
aircraft to shoot down uh the uh the the
Chinese uh collection balloon uh for
Carolina
um secretary Austin defense secretary uh
put a call through to his counterpart
China and the call was not accepted I
mean when we're at that point between
the superpowers that they're not talking
uh we're into a very vulnerable area
where cues can be misinterpreted and
this can lead to a much greater
consequences than the simple shooting
down of an unmanned object uh if an
aircraft with Americans or um you know
Western allies of some kind or on board
then that needs to be responded to and
when all of this perhaps could be
diffused by you know simple diplomacy
yeah and Mark I I think that um we're
expecting to hear from the Secretary of
Defense uh in the next couple hours
perhaps on this exactly and the fact
that the the sort of the hotline between
Washington and Beijing seems to be
breaking down will be of huge concern at
this point
yeah there's a really uh fascinating
story that that emerged about a year ago
which which really shows how important
that hotline is
um under the Trump Administration uh the
Chinese had got wind completely
incorrectly that America was about to
attack China uh this emerged in in a
book that was written about Donald Trump
a couple of years ago which has since
been confirmed that Mark milley who's
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs the top
American General had to call his Chinese
counterpart counterpart in Beijing to
say you might have heard that this is
about to happen it's not it's a mistake
take my word for it and the Chinese
General did take his word for it and
everything calmed down that is a very
very clear example of why these hotlines
are so important and as as has just been
said that hotline did not work last
weekend as soon as the Americans shot
down that balloon Lloyd Austin the U.S
defense secretary picked up the phone
tried to call the Chinese Secretary of
Defense Minister of Defense and the call
was not accepted that's really really
worrying and I think you can see how
this ratchets up because although the
Americans may have take them at face
value maybe they haven't got any uh spy
planes or spy drones over mainland China
at the moment but I'm sure they've got
um spy apparatus in the area around
southern China for example or or Taiwan
the Renegade Province as China calls it
they have probably got surveillance
activity taking place in areas that
China claims even if it's against
international law now if client China it
sees them as being aggressive in areas
that they claim you can see how they
they then may escalate and obviously the
ultimate concern is a manned aircraft
being shot down by one side or the other
that changes everything yeah Thomas come
back in on that um with your experience
as a chief of Defense staff how do you
turn down the tensions at a time like
this when the phone calls are going
unanswered and when there is so much a
mystery surround doing what's actually
happening
yeah well I think in the back rooms
um of the nation uh that could react in
other words the United States in this
case you need to really put the breakers
on uh you have to make sure that the
most aggressive voice is in there are
toned down a little bit and the
moderates uh get to speak out
um you know nothing is so bad that it
requires a massive response uh or an
immediate response
um you know I I certainly uh elected
politicians are under pressure from the
opposition and from their own civilians
part of that may explain why these
balloons have been shot down
um you know that President Biden took a
lot of heat on this
um you know when we're talking about
these things that could lead to much
greater confrontation between
superpowers you have to make sure that
those uh Things become more bipartisan
uh and toned down from one side continue
to try and open those discussions uh you
know that's a great story about Mark
milley with his Chinese counterpart uh
you know that speaks to the value of
keeping those lines open it certainly
does all right gentlemen that's a great
discussion let's just go to a final sort
of thought of question here we've kind
of touched on it but this is about the
way that we're monitoring the skies and
we're seeing these objects up there do
you think that what's happened over the
past few days is going to lead to an
increased um visibility for these kind
of objects and uh should there be more
money and research put into identifying
them early to try and sort of move away
from there being any um disagreement or
misunderstanding about what might be out
there Nick first to you
yeah absolutely we need to Def uh delve
deeper into this I mean this was a very
serious security breach by all accounts
the signals intelligence array on the
first balloon was capable of identifying
and perhaps intercepting Communications
perhaps very sophisticated systems so uh
you know we we've talked about the four
that we've found how many have we missed
uh absolutely more research and
investigation needed
and Thomas from YouTube expect to see
you know the radar the aperture is being
opened even wider I mean that would
suggest about so we're picking up a
bunch of stuff that perhaps we maybe
cause a bit more confusion than it's
worth
right and I I think that what uh will
happen as the apertures open is also be
honed where they're looking so uh
looking at approaches uh stratospheric
approaches to the West not going to pick
up a lot more it's it's not like opening
up your apertures and low level radar
and starting to pick up Cessna 150s and
Piper cups things like that
um but but I think it's it's very
important also to recognize that most of
the sensor equipment on the ground of
continental US and uh and Canada uh
dates back to the 1980s very little of
it has been upgraded now there's been a
lot of talk uh in recent months by uh
elected politicians in Canada in the
United States that billions will go into
this in uh in coming years I'm pretty
certain this will uh accelerate that
process and some of that will go towards
ensuring that slow-moving objects are uh
picked up with greater efficiency a
final thought from you then Mark because
we've seen the way that the U.S
politically has responded to this and
militarily responded to this the next
time that this sort of thing happens
next time that it's picked up and it
comes into the public domain I mean what
kind of response are we expecting to
seeks have to be very careful exactly
how this next one is dealt with I guess
yeah so look I I think you talk about
the public domain I think that is the
reason we're talking about all this had
the Chinese balloon not been spotted by
a member of the public in Montana
um the week before last then they it may
well never have been made public the
Americans may have let it float on over
the uh over the continent over
Continental America out into the
Atlantic they may have judged that it
had not picked up a great deal they may
have learned something from it and then
that would have been it the apertures
the filters on The Radars wouldn't have
changed and all of these new UFOs
wouldn't have been
um discovered the point that they have
is probably helpful for the Americans
because they now know the extent to
which this is happening if indeed it is
the Chinese pushing the boundaries
testing America's red lines
um but but yeah I think politically it's
very difficult for President Biden he
needs to be seen to be strong he's
facing an election not like not that far
away if he stands again he wants to be
seen to be strong he's facing criticism
from the writer politics but at the same
time he he knows that diplomatically as
we've discussed this is very delicate
stuff it certainly is okay Mark Stone
our U.S correspondent Thomas Lawson
former Chief of Defense staff for the
Canadian Armed Forces and Nick Pope a
UFO investigator for the ministry of
Defense here in the UK appreciate it
both all uh guys thank you very much for
being with us
all right you are watching Sky News and
still to come the report revealing
Liverpool fans have been cleared of any
wrongdoing following the trouble at last
season's Champions League final all the
details coming up after the break
[Music]
thank you